Ah, this one does look kind of uh it's kind of doesn't look
>> Oh, no.
OH, NO. YOU'RE A VERY very weird community. I just need you all
to know that, okay? Well, she until you know it kind of looks
like she's bought a little bit
>> You are disturbing me. You are just You are You are
weird. You are a weird
All right. So, Extra Emily
>> crazy stuff going on, all right? Extra Emily exposed
for view botting. Desktop view gets another one, guys. So, what
we had happen yesterday was Emily was streaming and she pulls
up a browser tab that includes basically her paying for view
bots, all right? Who is Extra Emily? Extra Emily is an OTK influencer.
She's a big Twitch streamer. Maybe not as big as we thought,
all right? She's a big streamer on Twitch, massive. She also
acts like a child a lot and it's very off-putting, okay? Um she's
sort of like this cutesy, innocent person who's really not like
that. Like she's not innocent. And maybe she's like cutesy in
in real life, but she's not anywhere near as innocent as she
plays. She does this like pretending to be a child for questionably
interested audience, all right?
As I don't care though, I don't care though says it in a far
less sensitive way than I just said it, all right? She might
be baiting a certain kind of audience that are very weird.
Um how are you accusing a 31-year-old
of being a baiter? Um because she acts like she's a 12-year-old
woman, that is why. Let's take a look at the view botting itself,
all right? viewbot.ai she alt tabs Oh, this alt tab on desktop
view is what gets everybody, isn't it?
This is This view gets
everybody, it's crazy. This is what got Atrioc by the way. This
is literally what got Atrioc. This got Atrioc. When you alt tab
and you and you pull this up at it's showing all of the Chrome
instances you have and H raw got caught with the AI generated
porn and now she's been caught with a view bot side up, okay?
Alt tab right now. I can't alt tab cuz I only I only ever stream
in windowed view dialogist.
I'll never stream in desktop view. That's crazy to do, all right?
That's totally
>> Oh, this is Emily. Have you met her? >> Yes, Chris.
>> Bring it on. >> Was there a reason why you were
late to >> Um I I had to put >> Oh, this is Emily.
Have you met her? >> Yes, Chris. >> Okay, so again,
oh, she Oh, this is different. This is actually the the view
when you Is this when you mouse over? Yeah, when you mouse over
your Chrome tabs. You bought that AI. Now, sorry, what I'm looking
for here, I'm also just getting some updates on this segment
as well, okay? But what I'm looking for is does she realize what
she pulled up there automatically? Does she Does she get it?
>> Does she see like immediately and try to click off or
>> Bring it on. >> Was there a reason why you were
late to >> I I had to put >> Oh, this is Emily. >> I
don't think she gets it. I don't think she sees. Do you think
she sees? Bro, if she Well, she's not She's scrolling cuz she
mouse over this Chrome icon, right? She She mouse over this Chrome
icon, but I think she'd like click off of it or something. She
smirks. >> Bring it on. >> Was there a reason why
you were late >> Oh, it's it's there, but it's like it's
I feel like she's focused up here and she barely looks at what
that is. On the clip without the zoom?
Do we have the clip without the zoom? Hold on. Um If somebody
wants to like that, they can. All right. The funny thing is is
basically this popped up and it was like a controversy.
But the person who blew it up, funny
was Mizkif.
I thought it was crazy that Mizkif blew this up cuz I thought
Mizkif was like friends with Emily.
And Mizkif kind of put the dagger in her back, okay? Mizkif went
insane proving this out. Mizkif went all the way above and beyond.
Okay, hold on. We've got this right here, this clip right here.
Yeah, who doesn't view bot nowadays? >> Emily, have you
met her? >> It's Chris.
bring it on. >> I I really don't think that's enough to
say that was the interaction, to be honest with you. Maybe it
was, maybe it wasn't. Is MissKif also a view botter? Uh people
say that, yeah.
I'm sure at OTK there's there was view botting that went on.
I I just I don't know if she saw it, okay?
Now, what does this prove? I can't see that she signed in. This
proves that she's looking at view bots, all right? This actually
doesn't prove that she's bought view bots. In fact, it looks
like the pop-up here, she's not a repeat customer cuz the support
pop-up is like, "Hey, can I help you purchase something from
our website?"
So, this in and of itself wouldn't prove that she's view botting.
It would prove that she's looking at view bots, but in and of
itself it would not prove view botting for sure. And I believe
we watch MissKif of all people step in to start actually proving
out that it is view bots, that she is actually view botting.
Okay, so this is the big one. Is MissKif does end up talking
to the website admins who are willing to send him stuff, okay?
>> What do we see?
>> Paid with Stripe. Her contact info was Mythic Talent.
Oh, Emily, bro. >> Why would the admins reveal this? Well,
MissKif is saying that they did, that the admins of the website
sent him a bunch of information.
But they nuking themselves hard by leaking that she bought the
bots from them? You would think so. Dude, the apparently he talked
to the guy from the website, okay?
Hold on, let's go to this No Limiters clip, right? >> I bought
AI website server, okay?
>> Oh, okay. So, he went to the server. So, they give you
a URL and you can join through that URL, and then he talked to
somebody from that website.
Like somebody who's like a an admin on that Discord. >> Is
the extra Emily thing real?
>> Oh boy. >> So, that's from the guy that owns the
>> Can I ask you why you wanted to make it public that
she bought the bots?
She [__] it up herself, so whatever.
>> What do you mean?
>> Yeah, I Here's the thing.
Here Here's the thing.
I don't know that this website is real.
I feel like I'm going to need somebody to go to that website
and buy view bots and see that it works. Not Not Don't do it
for me. I don't want my view botted. Don't I'm saying that some
influencer somewhere is going to have to go buy view bots from
this website and make sure they actually work, okay?
if they don't work, if it's not a real like it could just be
a fake website and somehow she opens that tab and then this guy
is like saying all of this, right? Saying, "Oh yeah, well, she
buys view bots from us." Maybe they're marketing with this. Maybe
they're just trying to get people to sign up. I'm not totally
sure.
But it could also just be like a fake website and the guy's like
[__] around. He like emailed it to a bunch of people
and they've clicked on it or some
But But why would you put on your page that you work with Clav
and stuff? Wouldn't those people also get mad that you're leaking
that?
I feel like this is not going to be reliable. I feel like this
is not going to be proof.
I I'm finding this person like unreliable. Like a lot of the
things they're saying seem unreliable to me.
>> I have no doubt that Miss Kif is talking to somebody
from the Discord that that that company runs or whatever and
that he joined it and and found this person and they're who they
say they are. They run the website. I don't know if the website's
actually selling view bots and I don't know if Emily bought them
yet. >> The text is too small for my 4K TV. Oh, [__]
I'm sorry, dude. I'm Like my bad.
Okay. He said, "Not [snorts] really. We worked with their management
teams in the past for some of their events.
It's mostly in bed so all legit traffic to boost them higher
on important
>> Yeah, I man, this whole thing feels really weird. Now,
I do need a time stamp for this. I have to go find the time stamp
for this, guys. Since they just did the same content, Emily,
5k viewers, 2k chatters. Emiru, 17k viewers, 2k chatters. Cool.
I see. >> All right. So, this is Extra Emily's Twitch tracker.
Let's see.
14,000, 12,000. She was killing it here. Bro, she had such a
good 2025. It's actually kind of sad. Like, she had such a good
2025 and this year has just been nothing but [__]
She needs another uh school, university, or whatever. That's
what she
>> Yeah, he's going to >> Don't you average 10k viewers,
you are falling off hard. Uh-oh. That's scary. Uh I would recommend
probably >> This is crazy that the fall off into 2026.
But, do we think this is just broadly like Twitch killing botting
a
I think that's probably what it is, right? Is she just figured,
oh well, we're going to have to go live with the real the real
view count for a while. >> probably doing something, maybe
going on a charity train. But, the next month she goes to 15k,
streaming university,
followers. I'm sure literally none of them ever came back to
her stream. >> Statistics, pal.
>> So, 15,000, 135,000
uh followers, right? That's pretty good. >> is two E's
that have cheated.
Then, 91,000 followers the next month. Emily is killing it. Do
I think she's view botting here? No. I don't think she's view
botting here. I think she's just getting these followers and
she's just doing really well.
She had a ton of hype last year. I think this is the Elden Ring
stream with with Agent, right? We were all hoping that they were
going to stay together. I was so surprised to find out that uh
that did not happen. Really [__] me up on Polymarket.
91,298
followers, 16,000 viewers. That's insane. That's a lot. Uh I
don't think she was view botting though, because I
>> Is he implying that Agent and Emily were >> Everyone
was just obsessed with, are they going to date? Is Agent going
to date her? Or is she going to date Synna? Uh which girl that
was on my stream 24/7 is he going to go after, right? I I just
couldn't find out. Uh I didn't really care cuz the next month
I got canceled. So, 25,000 followers and 9,758 viewers, still
pretty normal. I don't think she's view botting here. October,
she's doing IRL. I don't think she's view botting. She just fell
off pretty hard, right? The W community doesn't watch
>> I mean, the WL community is significantly botted, Miz.
Come on. I'm sure they I'm sure they transfer some of those bots
over when people are
But they come on, man. Come on, man. Be Be serious.
There's a ton of botting in that community, too. I don't know
about Agent specifically, but that community has a ton of botting.
Mizkif exposes
LSF mod for letting users target him, deleting defense posts,
using old clips against him, and saying he's considering a lawsuit.
They start looking through this moderator on Mizkif's stream,
okay?
And they as they go through this moderator's history, they start
to realize this moderator
is not unbiased, okay?
This moderator
intentionally with Mizkif. We're going to today. So, Mizkif opens
up his stream and he is upset, all right? He is not
>> Um I never view botted. So, there's a It's like what
is the definition of view botting compared to embedding? >> He
says >> Embedding is basically just a more expensive view
botting, right? It's legal. So, there's view botting, which is
illegal. View botting is when you are buying just bots that are
constantly coming to you. Embedding is technically legal because
it is what they do on the Twitch website. Embedding is the front
page of Twitch. So, when you go to the front page
>> This This gets tricky. So, I actually have some experience
with this because of how Destiny's website worked when I would
stream, right? Is view botting even illegal? Technically, under
the TOS, viewership manipulation for all of these platforms is
very illegal. Yes.
Against the TOS for all these platforms.
Will they ever enforce it against like the biggest talents on
their platforms?
But technically it is illegal, okay?
with DGG, that website, you do embed through that, and you embed
on Twitch, and you embed on YouTube. On YouTube, I had had like
YouTube email me and say, "We've readjusted your like payout
for something because of viewership
Right? Kick, I believe my viewership on stream as well, saying
that they thought or it seemed like their rudimentary botting
thing when I used to get embedded in DGG. That also the viewership
for the stream. But I messaged the the moderators or whatever
for Kick, and I was like, "Hey, it gets embedded over here, and
they're real views, but like you've let another person on this
platform do it the same way." And I think they whitelisted my
my
Oh, in terms of the law, well, it's probably fraud.
Like you could probably get, you know, it's probably fraud in
some ways, but I don't know. It's I don't know if it's um I It'd
be difficult to prove and run
I would I would guess it's fraud, especially when you do it for
sponsorships. In any case, yeah, and it's very easy to track
where your streams are being embedded from. So, the idea that
it's the same that embedding through a third-party website is
the same as embedding on the front page of Twitch, no, you know
where the embeds are coming from. You know that Twitch will literally
show you where your viewership is coming from, where you're embedded.
They track that. They know that, right? So, if you look at stats,
and you've been embedding for a long period of time, you'd probably
have whatever website's embedding you, you probably know like
what bot site is embedding you, or whatever, you know, front
they're using, whatever website they're using as a front for
that, okay?
yeah, I I don't agree here. That's all to say, I don't agree
here that embedding is just always allowed. You'd probably need
some proof that there's real legitimate engagement going on there,
and that it's not fake. Like for all the people who own the white
forest sites as well, I'm guessing Twitch would not really be
concerned about them
and getting, you know, increased viewership that way, because
all of those people have legitimate engagement, and it is through
a different site, and they're using like they they will have
less of a problem with it, okay? Also, Twitch will serve the
ads. But, for people who are doing it disingenuously, who are
like, you know, a one-pixel pop-up on some website, I think that's
way way way way way different. >> This is an embed. They're
not really going to pay attention to watch this, but it's in
the front of your stream. This is what we used to pay for, right?
I used to pay for this for some of my events and things.
>> That is not a consequential difference. I'm I'm sorry.
That is essentially
That's I don't think that's real. Um maybe you could argue that
it's like on a popular website. I know the Extra Life people
or Effects for Life or whatever, they used to do stuff like I
don't know. I think you would need some argument for why it's
the focus of the page, why it's the only focus of the
>> And uh it's legal. And it's something that's very hard
for Twitch to get rid of. I'm sure Paeon, maybe not because he's
a cigarette-smoking uh fiend, was on the front page of the battle.net
website. That's embedding, you know? Uh that's what you did.
>> It's not the same thing. Like, the embedding you get
naturally through events and stuff, they're going to allow that
cuz that's building traffic, that's sending traffic to their
site. Disingenuous embedding that people would just sell to you
on a regular basis, that's that's very very very different. Unless
you're like paying event organizers to embed your your website,
and you're not going to like If there's a service that's like
a botting service that allows you to get embedded views through
some, you know, scheme they're doing, that's very different.
So, it would just depend on, I guess, a case-by-case >> Ew.
But, it's expensive as I mean, you can't do it every day unless
you're a maniac. It's expensive as [__]
it's a lot. Viewbotting's really cheap. I mean, I think Emily
was like, what, $280 for 200 viewers or some [__]
So, I it I don't really give a [__] about the fact
that Extra Emily viewbotted, and I'm sure none of you care, either.
Like, I just don't care. I don't I said I feel bad for her. You
know, this isn't like 2022 and we have no drama going on
>> I feel bad for her. I'm going to keep bringing this
up. I'm going to keep making sure that everybody knows that she
is lying, that she is disingenuous. She's a piece of But I don't
I don't like judge her and
kind of funny >> extra life is view botting. Well, there
was a difference between extra life. Extra life would have view
bought 40,000 viewers, be at the top of every section when there
a new game came out, and that was the problem. Was he literally
took over the website with view bots, right? But extra
>> that he was like next level with it, that he was better.
>> Emily having a thousand extra viewers that she bought,
I just don't give a [__] Like that is that really
a huge issue? Is it really a >> Uh, I love Miz, but it
feels to me a little bit more like this is an argument you make.
Sort of in the same vein as the people who are like, "Well, I
just think like Sliker is cheating and you know, people cheat.
That's like what people do. What are you going to get mad at
them? It's not even illegal."
Right? It's like the thing where
I'm sure you feel like it's important to take this position.
I'm sure you feel that it's important to take this position on
something that you may or may not have done. Uh, it's just how
it feels. It's the same aura going on here. I like Mizkif. I'm
not I'm not trying to talk [__]
I'm just I'm just giving it to you in a real way.
>> trying to be real. >> really care. I also don't
really care because extra life tries so hard as a content creator
and she actually puts in so much effort that it doesn't really
bother me because at least she's view botting, right? My problem
is like if you if these people who are embedding or view botting
when they're not trying because they're not like they're just
basically utilizing that to say like, "Look, I'm the biggest
streamer. Look, I'm big and I'm doing this." But I don't really
care that extra life embedded a thousand viewers or or view bought
a thousand viewers when she has 7,000 real viewers. And I guarantee
you if you told any sponsor that, they wouldn't give a [__]
either. They'd be like, "All right, whatever. I don't really
care." >> I'm going to go through this cope. I don't want
to be on this cope anymore. I'm good with not being on this stuff
at
Okay, here we go. Here's where we get to the post being removed,
okay? >> from someone that there was an LSF post about
me that had more than one upvote. And not only did it have more
than one upvote, it had 700 upvotes in an hour. And I didn't
know this. This wasn't posted on my disc- >> Oh, that's
got to be brutal for Mizkif because I think Mizkif
feels like LSF is totally slanted against him. I and justifiably
so. Like whenever his stuff's on LSF, it gets massively downvoted,
okay? Massively
So, I understand that finally one post breaks through and they
immediately delete it. Oh, boy. >> So, they can't say it
was brigaded. Literally
no
recognition whatsoever. No camps- like they can't say, "Oh, Mizkif's
were were pushing this. Mizkif's were doing this." It was an
upvoted post by me of me. And it was about ExtraEmily view botting
and the owner of the website said it was
Today, I'm going to go over and show you how Live Stream Fail
moderators have been constantly banning and removing my content
ever since the uh allegations and have been purposely perpetuating
their own reality of what they want the content of viewers to
see and how they have been doing this and deleting posts of mine
and have been making it look like that everyone hates me on LSF
and making sure that I get no grounds to do it. They do this
on purpose. And this >> Why are they deleting it? This
one, I don't know why they deleted this one. I do know they they
like broadly
I like it's not the mods who are
How do I put this? There's like two There's multiple different
parties that all don't like Mizkif for different
And so like a lot of the viewers, if there's just a neutral Miz
clip or it's just like Miz is doing something funny, it'll get
massively downvoted, right? This is because it's drama about
another creator that this would have been massively upvoted and
then the mods come in and do seem to delete the thread.
Yeah, I see that there's a mod team explanation. We'll get to
it after we We're going to go through the timeline. I know there's
an explanation out now. >> perfect example. This has been
happening non-stop. So, this got removed. A post about me literally
showing that the mod the the the person who has created the
for this uh viewbot,
this person uh the got removed by the mod moderator because I
showed that the the guy who owns the the viewbotting website
on his Discord said and showed me the receipt that it was Extra
Emily. So, it got upvoted like crazy, all I know a lot of streamers
do it and try to hide it, but I feel like unequivocal proof of
viewbotting should be met with a permaban, but what do I know?
600 upvotes, okay?
>> It It should be. Like, unfortunately, like you're you're
incentivizing everybody to viewbot. Everybody is massively incentivized
to viewbot. Basically, they're telling you if you don't viewbot
on these platforms, you're
And I It just feels like a major issue, man. Like, I What am
I supposed What am I supposed to do over here, man? What are
we doing over here, man?
What are we doing?
What are we doing out here? You're telling me that you're never
going to punish people and there's only upsides to it.
I don't know. I still feel like I For some reason, it just still
strikes me as wrong, but it I I Why? I Again, it's like a slave
morality thing that is
actually just detrimental to any success in the world. >> No
hate here whatsoever. How is not an automatic permaban? Blah
blah blah.
Uh seems kind of weird for the shares owner to share this. Mods
about to remove the post. They are bought and paid for. And it's
crazy how this post has no reason to be removed whatsoever. But,
somehow iPad dozens and dozens of posts of mine that actually
get upvoted or a good post to me get removed for zero reason
whatsoever, okay?
>> I I do feel like it's I'm going to try to support Miz,
but cut through the hyperbole. Dozens, I don't know about dozens.
But it has been a time like it seems like a pattern to me that
his stuff does get downvoted and when something does break through,
it's like, well, we don't like Miz, we're getting rid of it.
It it seemed that way. I've I've experienced that pattern. I
don't have like perfect evidence of it, but I have seen that
pattern. >> This post was doing great. I didn't even know
it existed. I wasn't on my my Discord, so you can't say it was
brigaded. I was literally not even on the computer and somehow
it had 700 upvotes in an hour, then gets removed immediately.
Here's your reason why it got removed immediately. This is a
screenshot from the main moderator on of this website that I
messaged. I said uh why was there no reason for this ban?
Uh-oh, this is the this is the LSF
He's messaging him directly, which I think we've laughed about
in the past. But it's it's crazy that he's messaging him directly.
I think Violet Motion is the person who they removed. I think
this is actually the person themselves
that ends up getting removed. Here I am getting some water. >> say
removed by moderator. Here's the reason why we removed it. They
didn't even give me a reason. They didn't have a reason for the
person. They just removed it. Sorry, this post has been removed
by moderations of LSF. They didn't even say why. They just removed
it because it makes me look
Now, here's what the moderator the head moderator tries to claim,
okay?
But before we watch that, I want to show you guys a video that
someone made in my community yesterday.
So, this is Violet Motion, the person that's fully in charge
of LSF, right?
This is Valenthius that he just showed you. Valenthius is a moderator
of Live Stream Fails.
Look at Valenthius' posts.
He's an extra Emily's Discord. He's a one-year subscriber.
And he's a moderator
of Mr. Arthur.
He is a Mr. Arthur moderator.
This guy
And it's ridiculous
how they try to say that they are unbiased or that the bias are
going to be very little. >> You get the idea. This guy
is like very in with OTK and he's a moderator for
for I guess Mr. Arthur, but he's a big fan of Extra Emily, okay?
>> But before we watch that, I want to show you guys a
video that someone made in my community yesterday.
So this is Violet Motion, the person that's fully in charge of
LSF. Look at Valentius's posts.
He's in Extra Emily's Discord. He's a 1-year subscriber.
And he's a moderator
of Mr. Arthur.
He is a Mr. Arthur moderator.
This guy
>> Uh not just that, okay? Not just that, but if you go
to his logs for Extra Emily's chat, oh boy, oh boy, okay? This
guy
this guy be all over the Extra Emily
All right. Sorry. I The person who linked me this linked me with
the linked me with the shower text highlighted, which I'm guessing
is going to come into understanding why I guess I'll understand
why that happened.
Oh god, this guy. Couple days in August.
Not shower showering. Need to take a shower now. She wants to
skip a shower. Take your shower so bad. Shower time Emmy. Take
a shower first. Shower boss is coming. Shower shower plus brush
teeth. Shower time. 1-minute shower and 2-minute changing. Fake
shower. Yes, we hear it, but it's a fake shower. Shower
Apparently this guy, this Valentius guy, is very closely tracking
It's a meme. Is it a meme? It's an Extra Emily meme?
Okay, apparently they are very closely tracking her shower experience,
okay?
Suffice to say
6,000 messages in just April, okay? 6,000 messages in her chat.
He's a viewer of Extra Emily, okay? He's a fan. He's a friend
of Extra Emily.
Fan, maybe not friend.
>> And it's ridiculous
how they try to say that they are unbiased or that the bias are
going to be very >> Oh, this is This is the really disturbing
thing though, isn't it, Azo? This is the really This is the actually
disturbing thing. Now we're plus brush teeth, it's time to go
to bed, Emmy. Emmy, it's time to go to bed. We're going to put
you Emmy, we're going to put you bed. Time to brush your teeth,
Emmy.
Uh you are disturbing me. You are just You are You are weird.
You are a weird community. You're a very, very weird community.
I just need you all to know that, okay? >> very little
when you're a literal moderator of Mr. Arthur and a 1-year sub
to Extra Emily. Like that is complete biasness.
It's ridiculous. He's even posting nonstop Keep in mind, this
guy Valentius chat, look at this, has 1,700
messages in Extra Emily's server.
in Extra Emily's server alone.
I will say
you do need to see the broad context of how they engage to know
like how devoted a fan they are, all right? Just showing that
he's got 1,700
I'm like, okay, what are the messages for the most part? Now,
I will say damning one right at the top for Mizkif is this guy's
linking an EmmyRu clip in Extra Emily's Discord.
All right? But if he's not like I would look for, you know, what
has this guy said about
Has this guy said anything about Miz?
Miz? Miz in March?
Miz in February?
Like does he mention Mizkif at all? Miz?
I don't see him mentioning Mizkif at Right? So it's like Is he
showing off anti-Miz bias? Not necessarily in the Twitch logs,
okay?
We do have to take a look We have to take a little bit of a look
at what he actually says and what he actually does. So, yeah,
he participates in Extra Emily's. Maybe he's got some reason
to protect her. I don't know if it's anti-Miz bias or pro-Emily
bias, though, okay? Does he see some evidence of anti-Miz bias?
>> removed by Valenteus for no reason. Keep in mind, no
reason. They didn't even put a reason. They usually put a reason.
No reason whatsoever. They just completely swept it. Why? Because
it's a clip of me, and it's also a clip making Extra Emily look
bad.
Look at the reason why the head moderator Violet Motion tells
me it got removed. There was a lot of reports on the validity.
My mods
tried a few dozen times, and one of them was able to get the
same pop-up, and multiple people were saying the same.
Eventually asked for a video of it happening, and no one could
produce it. >> Little suspicious, little suspicious. >> I
then literally tell them >> with the site. I've no way
of telling. The new thread should still be left up with a neutral
title. I don't know why a removal reason wasn't added. They said
they were going to do >> Actually, they were lying, and
that she had the pop-up before she even went on the 67 website.
She had the pop-up before she even went to the website.
And this guy's trying to be like, "As for your other point, no
one wants to be mod for LSF is unbiased. I can only have two
reasonable people that acknowledge their bias and mod appropriately."
I think that's completely fair to say. You're always going to
have a bias, right? Everyone does. But to say that it's not even
a bias is one thing. 1,800 in one Discord, 1,800 comments in
one Discord, constantly posting things, and then also being a
moderator in Mr. Arthur's chat, while also having thousands of
messages in Nick Palm's Discord. Yeah, I think that's a difference
between being a little bit biased and extremely biased. And also,
how you just constantly remove posts of me whenever it makes
you look look like a makes me look good, and you only let up
the posts that are completely terrible with me. You also not
only do that, you have banned so many of my viewers and of people
that defend me. And you basically made it so everyone on LSF
are people that just don't ever want to even give me a chance
and they're bots. But the people that have tried to give opinions,
the people that have tried to show reason with my with my >> Okay.
I see what he's saying. So basically his argument is something
along the lines of Okay.
Like Yeah, you banned all of my all the people who support me.
It's actually in fact I believe I hear if you just tune your
ear a little bit Is this not something akin to the Mr. Girl argument?
Well, if you ban everybody who supports me, then all the people
who are going to be left are the people who hate me. So yeah,
you're [__] me over even though you're not It is,
right? It's just the It's the Mr. Girl argument. Now he's not
friends with the moderators of LSF. It's a little different.
But really it is kind of the same thing that nobody really denies.
It's obviously true.
>> logic, you completely banned them every single time.
And so many of my people have been banned and so many people
have been banned on LSF for just trying to have a conversation
about me. Not even trying to defend me, trying to have a conversation.
There's more, by the way.
This is the next one of the moderator Virtual Signal.
>> Did you read that? Virtual Signal. >> He's also
a very active viewer and person in ExtraEmily's Discord yet >> Virtual
Signal. No, no, no. Okay. >> Like what? >> Cool,
cool, cool, cool. >> These people are so biased. And they
straight up have banned so many of you and they just let everyone
just dogpile and lie about me and not even give me a chance with
any of my opinions. Like don't you think it's kind of crazy,
chat, that for 6 months I have shown proof and I have shown that
Emmy has lied and I've shown a validation to my claims and all
they have done is just zero upvotes. When the entire >> So
they can't control that. That's That's just all the viewers,
right? They can't control who gets upvoted and downvoted. Really?
I mean, I get the argument that, "Hey, my people get banned when
they, you know, defend me or something." I get that. But, there
is a whole thing going on where you have to deal with the fact
that a lot of the LSF viewers, a lot of people who are or sorry,
the LSF users are Asmongold
And those people, by definition, are going to despise you. Right?
Like, Asmongold does rule that subreddit.
His fans rule that subreddit. And you're unfortunately somebody
who's hated by Asmongold. And the mods can't really help it all
that much, right? Yeah, yeah, it's like I I literally don't know
how you fix this, to be honest with you. But, there is a funny
cut coming up, so we got to keep going, okay? >> they're
coming to light that it's that she's lied. Somehow, LSF is the
only place that wants to pretend that it doesn't exist. It's
because the moderators are deleting clips. It's not the people.
It's that moderators are deleting clips, and moderators are deleting
comments, and they're banning people for even having a conversation
about me. They are biased as And I get what this person Violet
Motions trying to say, that I understand that yes, it could be
like a little bit biased, and everyone's going to be a little
bit biased. I get that. But, for her to say that it's completely,
you know, that it's not completely biased to the point where
it's a problem, when your moderator deleted the post claiming
that he got the same pop-up, but he never sent you the video
when you asked for it. So, he just deleted it, lied to you, and
said, "Yeah, by the way, uh that And then he just never gave
you the video. He couldn't produce it. >> It does feel
I understand why he's upset, cuz it feels like he's start starting
to break through. And one one argument he could make here is
that he wants to change the opinions of these people on LSF who
don't like him. But, then when one of his clips is actually hitting
the front page, it's deleted. So, like, he has no way Basically,
they're being like, "Well, we can't control it." And then you
start like climbing uphill this grind to try to win back the
approval of some LSF users. And you finally start getting a little
traction, and then the mod team steps in and like kicks you in
the face, right? You're like climbing up the side of this mountain
that's like sheer, and the mod team leans out from a cave and
just like kicks you in the face as you're climbing up the mountain.
It feels I get it. >> And you're trying to tell me that
this Reddit is not
biased as hell, and that the moderators are not banning and deleting
things, and purposely putting their own narratives on things.
And I understand what you guys say, who cares about LSF? LSF
is the seed that builds the tree into things. LSF is the place
that I've gotten canceled not only once, twice, three times,
four. I've been canceled here so many times because it's the
start of it. It's where people will will post things and talk
about things.
>> Uh I think I generally disagree with this. I think this
is um I I I disagree that you could really change things from
here. I think you got to go build your own seed, which he's doing
with the Clippy Discords and >> And the fact that they're
willing to just let nobody have an opinion of me unless you get
permanently banned. Nobody can have an opinion of their queens
unless they get permanently banned, and they purposely make it
an echo chamber. >> Oh, are they simping Do you have evidence
they're simping for Emiru and Extra Emily? If you If you have
proof of simping, I want to see that. Show me the proof of simping.
>> So, no conversations can be held. Yeah, that's a problem.
That is a issue.
Bring Stail back.
I think Stail should be in charge of the Reddit again. BRING
HIM >> BRING STAIL BACK NOW. Bring Bring He's arguing they
should bring Stail back.
I don't particularly care who mods LSF, to be honest with you.
I don't. But I just thought it was really funny that he argues,
"Bring Stail back. Bring Stail back now."
Where is Stail? I don't know what Stail's doing right now. He's
doing >> held. Yeah, that's a problem. That is a
Bring Stail back.
I think Stail should be in charge of the Reddit again. Bring
him back because he wasn't some biased dude. He is very calculated
with what what thinks. That guy actually cares more than anyone
else. Bring him back on the Reddit. I don't care what he did.
Stail actually cares. He was someone that truly cared about the
LSF community >> Ooh. Happy to chat about this Mischa by
the way, Stail 2000.
Let's go. Let's go. >> the the the community in general.
You should bring him back because your biased moderators that
have 1900 comments in just Extra Emily's Discord alone, moderators
in Extra in Arthur's Discord, and also all over Nick's Nick's
Nick's Discord. That's just biased as
and they're deleting threads for no >> You need a Miz You
need a Miz mod. Where's your Miz Where's your Miz Kif advocate,
okay? Where's the Miz Kif advocate? I don't see one. I don't
see anybody who likes Miz. You got all this You got all these
biased people in there. Where's one guy who likes Miz? Tell me.
Where they at? Where they at, dog?
They're all banned. Well, Miz Kif's going to Miz Kif's going
to look at his Stail's chat logs. We'll We'll check it
Yeah, I screwed up by recruiting some super fans to LSF mod team
because I was sick of the mod drama and I could just overrule
them as the top mod. Ironically, that came back to bite me and
now they have killed the subreddit with me gone. Yeah, I recruited
them because they posted only positive clips to LSF. That was
why I brought them on. XD. Unfortunately. Oh, so Wait, Stail's
literally responsible for the problem Miz Kif's describing. Oh
boy. Oh no. Come on, man. Come on, Stail.
Wow. Oh boy.
>> They posted tons.
Oh, bro. You hired the wrong people.
>> You So, you got people that are emotionally attached
and parasocial to content creators. >> OH, NO.
OH, NO. >> AND THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN, RIGHT? THERE'S GOING
TO BE BIASED no matter what, but like I think they're >> I
thought Stail I thought Stail was like really really really really
really intentful and and logical with what he did. Come on, man.
>> overly biased to the point where it's obviously ruining
the problem. Um It's It's why uh It's It's exactly why my clips
get removed. You see other clips getting removed. You see The
one in chat have you been banned from LSF because you just had
a conversation about me. Not even defending me or but just having
a conversation. And it's like you get banned from the [__]
Look at how many ones there are. Look how many of you guys have
been banned >> Mhm. This is a very powerful argument, the
ones in the chat. I got it. Yeah, this feels this feels empiric.
Uh Empirical? This feels empirical. >> the Reddit for just
talking about me. How is that fair? How is that a fair in the
slightest that you just talking about me is going to get you
banned from the
Look how many ones there are.
>> Okay, we're going through his logs. We're going through
his logs. >> Something to the lines of if anyone wants
to [__] on Miz when this server goes up, the LSF
server is open.
>> Interesting. Okay, this guy seems bad. The virtue signal
guy? That seems like that guy hates Miz. That's way better evidence.
I like that.
We don't know if that guy banned Miz. I don't know if that guy
banned Miz. >> are allowing people to massively [__]
on
>> There's no I've not seen evidence yet that that guy
was the person deleting the chat or the the clips. >> And
that's okay. >> We're trying to find it. Try to see. >> On
10/26/2025
and that's perfectly okay.
But any other comments and everything else about your queens
and you delete
Is this not
I think I can sue this guy because he's straight-up allowing
anything to happen. It's the same reason why Remember >> I
Dude, you can't sue this. Come on, man. I don't think you can
sue this guy. I don't think so. I don't think so. I I don't think
so. >> how they were trying to use clips of me on LSF?
>> You got to You got to cut this language, man. You got
to Do not talk about suing people on a stream. Don't do it. Don't
do it. Don't be the Ethan Klein of the streamerverse. All right,
don't do it. >> with the cheese incident?
Like, you're trying to be like, "Yeah, look, dude, he's an abusive
boyfriend because he got mad about cheese one
3 years ago. Hey, look, he got mad at Cinna and said that she's
not his friend. True, she's not my friend.
And they posted all these clips on LSF from years ago. And when
I messaged the moderator and said that that's against TOS because
you you can't use old clips, and it's clearly biased, these clips.
You're not just posting these for fun, you're posting these to
go after me. They literally told me, "Sorry." But here's this
guy who's the moderator allowing anyone to go after me publicly
and saying it's totally okay. >> I would say that's indicative
of bias as
I think they should solve the Miss Kif bias issue on LSF, okay?
They should try to, you know, be more understanding of people
who do like him. Be understanding of his community.
I don't think that threatening lawsuits is the way to go about
getting that >> This is from Nick's Discord.
So in Nick's Discord
>> Okay, so >> already obviously going to be biased,
something to the effect of if anyone wants to [__]
on Miz when the server goes up, the LSF server is open. >> Oh,
Violet Motion got mad and said, "Bro, are we leaking DMs? Bro,
this LSF what drugs you >> What drugs am I on? >> I
didn't know that happened. I didn't see that in any of the clips.
Dude, the mod's like, "What What the [__] You're
leaking DMs with me?" >> Miz out here burning bridges for
drama.
Oh, is he leaking more DMs? >> I'll just send him exactly
the message that I just got shown. >> What Pull him on.
Pull him on. Wait, didn't Violet Motion Is that one of the guys
who came on my stream? Is he in my
I'm going to talk to this guy. >> Is Is Is this Is this
okay? >> Nope, don't have it. >> That message of
of a virtue signal saying that it's okay to completely [__]
on me, that it's okay to just [__] on me uh as much
as people want
and be on as biased as you want
from one of your mods?
>> You're mad
I'm leaking the DMs?
Like, I'm bro, I'm Yeah, I'll leak everything. I don't give a
[__] [__] that. What are you going to
cry and complain that I'm leaking DMs when you literally told
me that my mod tried a few dozen times and one of them was able
to get the pop-up, but then you asked a video for it and he couldn't
produce it. And I'm supposed to be just like, "Yeah, that's fine.
You only used clips obviously for months to perpetuate
>> It seemed like I will say the
Man, I just I feel like this is a tactical error. I feel like
this Violet Motion person was like actually speaking pretty like
neutrally to Mischa. And when when they say this, it seemed like
they were even saying
like, "Hey, Mischa asked for a video of it happening, they couldn't
reproduce it. I have no way of telling, so the new thread he's
like, oh, I did let it go back up. Like it's it's bad that they
couldn't reproduce it."
he's literally he's basically apologizing, I think. And saying
like this seems like it was not right the way it was handled.
Oh, man, the reaction to that by leaking the DMs is horrible,
but that >> But then you asked a video for it and he couldn't
produce >> Also, yes, it is demon time and we do appreciate
demon time and Mischa is providing me bountiful content for the
first part of the stream. So, you know, who am I to complain?
Who am I to complain? I'm here farming it too, so >> use
it. >> Each his own. >> And I'm supposed to be just
like, "Yeah, that's fine. You only used clips obviously for months
to perpetuate lies about me." Something to the effect of if anyone
wants to [__] on this when the server goes up, the
LSF server is open. LSF mod Virtual Signal has been simping in
Nick's Discord for a while. Tonight
took he took tonight he took a a two to another level. While
NMP was complaining about the hate threads, the mods came in
and agreed that court docs shouldn't be posted and LSF is unfair
towards him. >> It seems like this guy is really really
biased and probably should not be on the mod team. Who recruited
the Virtual Signal guy cuz that's rough. That's like just straight
up going to NMP's Discord, the guy who's like the most neurotic
about LSF, and just being his friend and like validating all
of his stupid neuroses, that feels like a little too far, man.
I don't know I don't know why that guy's a mod.
That's kind of embarrassing.
>> See what I mean? Life is good. Really enjoying the simple
things and not being a part of the Twitch rat race. Honestly,
if it wasn't for the LSF threads, I wouldn't even care about
it. Thanks for the virtue signal for that, by the way.
For what it's worth, which I know is nothing, I'm sorry that
LSF has been trashed towards you. I was very against the Henry
threads being allowed, but I don't have that kind of sway. True,
I I don't think I don't think the threads even should be allowed
scrapping court docs for is level beyond even
In my opinion, not really that bad of a guy. I stay my lane,
don't do heavy politics or start drama, blah, blah, Reddit is
very good at taking things out of context, blah, blah, blah,
blah. I they're convinced that you're an egomaniac and because
>> Feel like every streamer at the moment is trying to
infiltrate LSF. If I was a top narcissistic streamer, I would
legit pay people to try and infiltrate the moderation team. Well,
it but it doesn't make any sense to me. As much as LSF is like
good for views and stuff, I really don't think
I It is Maybe I Maybe I'm understating it. I don't think you
can really infiltrate or control it that
Like every time it's overtly controlled in this kind of way,
there's massive blowback on the people it's controlled
It is I know it's not about reality. It's like the people want
to control it for themselves so that they can prevent like hate
from them from popping up on there, but literally every time
people try to control it, it literally it results in blowback.
Like it it strives end effects whatever drama is there. So, trying
to control it in that way doesn't even work in the first place.
But I I agree that all these people do want to control it. They
do want to have a say there, and it feels very funny to me that
they do. It's just goofy that
Yeah, I don't know. It's just better if you have like an overwhelming
presence there. Like if you have overwhelming fan base. I wouldn't
focus on the moderation staff. I just focus on like the users,
to be honest with you. >> Because they don't understand
their things. And yeah, you're probably right about the Melina
stuff. I still don't really understand exactly where it's coming
from, but once the community gets a hype on it for something,
it goes
But then that same guy is in Nick's Discord saying that you can
go nuts
about anything with me.
>> We're getting slammed out there by Miz >> Is it
Do we have a timestamp on this? When is this from?
Oh, uh sir, another EE bot post has has hit LSF.
You're getting slammed out there by Miz Kids. Yeah, you're going
after the Valentes guy with the chat messages. Feels like this
guy is the actual culprit, the virtue signal guy. If you're going
to say somebody likely is like deleting pro-Miz threads,
it's got to be the virtue signal guy,
I don't know why we went after the Valentes dude who, you know,
he just he's just a guy who likes spamming emotes and asking
if Extra Emily took a shower today.
What crime has he really committed?
I guess an adult. >> The same moderator. We're getting
slammed out there by Miz Kids. This guy is literally saying he
is one of the army, part of the army,
and then he can just play god on the Reddit, and that's totally
okay.
Are you serious? And out there by >> Oh, he's getting in
the fight with the LSF people.
>> This is Sounds great. >> Oh XQC lover, 15,000.
Oh, acting like you don't have viewers like, okay. >> I'm
a local that makes like 15 grand a day. That's That's a good
law I mean, chat, that's a good business, honestly. I'm a I'm
a great ape. >> He's making 15 grand a day? What the What
the heck? >> Gal, sounds great. >> lot, man. >> Go
and help us lick in the car again. Okay. I mean, as soon as Lacari's
done with his camp, I'll gladly go do that. I'll pick him up.
This is crazy. This is He was a super fan of >> I don't
I don't I actually don't really think. Oh, yeah.
Wait, does Oh, this guy was in Miz Kids' chat all the time. Do
we know that this guy like even hates Miz Kids? Do we even know
that he hates Miz Kids?
Uh yeah, I might cover that later. Ozil. That's the Beast Process
article, right?
I cover it later, maybe. >> When the server go >> It's
drama time right now. Is Lorna Box denying a genocide?
But, you'll have to stick around to figure it out, to find out,
okay? We'll cover the article, we'll cover his reaction to the
No Samson video. We'll check it all out. >> We're getting
slammed out there by the Miz kids and get her moved for no
>> This one has nothing to do with you. Valenteous is just
biased towards Extra Emily. Oh, I know.
I know. I I Well, I think it's two things. I do think it has
to do with me, and then I also think he's biased towards Extra
Emily.
I just hold on. Woof. I I just clicked on like a image that got
put in his chat. It's this.
Can't wait for mods to delete this one, too. They're really sweeping
for Tectone and Asmongold.
Sorry, I just I clicked on it and then I was like, "Whoa, I shouldn't
click an image out of his chat with no
>> He did. Yes. He does. Look at this. This like mods are
just going to sweep don't
Uh-oh. This guy is an OTK super fan.
>> That's all today, by the way.
We're still on 4/16, by the way.
This guy This guy is
Okay, he's he's proving once again this guy's hard drive needs
to be checked now. Check this guy Check this guy's hard drive
now. Not really proving he hates Miz yet. I mean, it's like he
hates Miz, I guess, if he loves one of these people. >> Anyone
actually go to the 67 website and get it to pop up? So, the answer
to my question is no. No one has got it to pop
So, even Nick agrees that you can't get it to pop up.
Wait, Valenteous just po- it posted
>> Oh, this is a Okay, this is this the best evidence he's
had so far, okay? This is better evidence than any of this stuff.
This is better evidence than any of it, okay? Emiru is on the
pro- in the process of filing and Volant is the one who posted
it.
That's tough. That's tough. That's tough. That's >> of
getting a filing a restraining order on Mizkif? Volant, when
are you going to post the update that it's been 6 months and
she still doesn't have the restraining order?
Are you When are you going to post that
It's been 6 months. When are you going to post the part where
she never got the restraining order in the first place? Cuz she
can't. Like, what? Why don't I just date PD Plastic? >> Okay,
we watching the Emiru clip that Volant posted. >> is worse.
Do not show it on stream. >> Oh, NO.
OH, NO.
ANOTHER Stale recruited bond.
Stale recruited another one. Oh my god, Stale recruited another
one. No shot. No shot.
>> A plane hit the second tower.
What is it What are your recruiting procedures, Stale? Can I
ask Can Can we talk to Stale about his recruiting procedures
for LSF? >> His Twitter is worse. Do not show it on
>> Send me his Twitter. I want to see it,
>> Hold on. Volant is
>> Beat your ass and hide the Bible with God watching.
Sometimes you
>> Honestly, Twitch just needs way more regulation that
it gets. Twitch needs way, way, way more regulation than it actually
gets. It's actually unacceptable, though. Low level of of regulation.
Bro, they're doing immeasurable harm to future kids, okay? It's
like a EPI playground is what it is. It's crazy. What about Kick?
Kick is not a platform that is anywhere near as geared towards
children. Kick is literally from its outset meant to be a platform
not for kids.
It's meant to be a platform for adults. That's literally the
goal they had from the very beginning. LSF came out and they
have removed one of these mods. I hope it's the virtue signal
person, but I don't know for sure. So, let me open up the thread
and we'll check it out right now, okay? It's 1 day ago.
All right. So,
yesterday, statement from the mod team by Violent Motion. Violent
Motion, of course, the the head mod on this subreddit currently.
Yesterday, a post about ExtraEmily on a website, viewbot.ai,
was posted on the subreddit. The original thread here was removed
by the removed by a member of our mod team. They stated, "I removed
this thread because it looks like the viewbot.ai website is the
is a pop-up from the 67 speed website that appeared when she
tried opened it to try the challenge." Trying to do due diligence,
multiple members of the mod team themselves tried, but could
not recreate the pop-up on our own end. We tried multiple browsers,
incognito, mobile, everything, and we could not recreate the
pop-up. The same mod that removed the original thread said that
they did recreate the pop-up by spamming the start button, and
we took their word on it. And started to remove threads and comments
that kept popping up about the situation. More threads and comments
popped up questioning why we would remove these threads and pushed
back on the claims that it was a pop-up. We tried to grab them
more proof, but they said that they could not recreate it and
suggested that the pop-up may have been removed. After that,
we decided to leave up a post with a more neutral title. Today,
it started to become more apparent that the moderator may have
lied or fabricated the claim of a pop-up to seemingly protect
ExtraEmily.
Through more digging, we were able to confirm that they are an
avid ExtraEmily clipper, poster, and a very active member of
her community in Discord. Mods are going to have biases and be
viewers, but we cannot allow that bias to influence how we moderate
or what rules we follow. Oh, maybe it was Violent This. Maybe
it was Violent This.
Listen, probably I'll be real, probably just not a bad idea to
get rid of that whole that guy. Listen, it didn't go well for
Miz or sorry, it didn't go well for Stale when he had to defend
the fact that he's got like a uh a total on his mod team, either,
okay? That was rough.
So, Violent Motion, congrats to you. You could use this controversy
to purge one of the lollies.
take a look at the rest of those stale recruited guys and understand
that it's very likely a pervasive problem, okay? The sidebar
might list the mods, we can check it in just a second. We still
have not been able to recreate the pop-up and neither has other
have other communities that tried. With all that being said,
we decided to remove this mod from the team. We promise to be
more transparent
in our moderation and if we screw up, we think it's important
to be open about it. Thank you to the members of the community
who reached out to challenge the original claims of the pop-up.
Not going to lie, guys, awesome step in the right direction.
No politics plus this, I skeptical that it was going to be more
of the exact same because VM somehow stayed through stale, but
I've been won over. Good job, guys. Glad to see you've restored
team decisions and sanity. Good
Good move and I'm sure many will appreciate the transparency.
Damn.
People be loving this. Okay, moderators, we have virtu- Oh, virtue
signal still here. Virtue signal's here, so it's got to be Valenthis
then. Valenthis is Valenthis is maybe? Was that how we said it?
Well, hey, listen.
Sometimes bias works. So Sorry, sometimes like seeing someone
who's biased against you and just calling it out, sometimes that
works. I saw people saying they were getting banned asking for
the mods evidence. That should be reverted. First I'm hearing
about this, please encourage anyone to email the mod team or
to message modmail again or DM me if they can't so we can look
into it. Bro, Miskif kind of totally won on this one, didn't
he? Miskif bent bent LSF to his will. Damn. Looked it up.
Oh boy, I This doesn't mean anything. This is This is dire for
the future of um the Western world, okay?
6464 messages.
Bro, they're all emotes. The guy just spams emotes during his
stream. Is it really that evil to spam emotes during a
Come on. Now, listen. Unfortunately,
the streams he was spamming emotes in told us more about him
than any of the conduct he was actually taking part in,
you All your messages are in Extra Emily's chat and Emery Rose's
chat
for days and days and days on end?
I Again, it's just a it's that's concerning. That's concerning.
It's very concerning.
>> This is actually a way better point than anybody than
what anyone's made so far. A big streamer has a view botting
tab open. Yeah, my first guess is it was an accidental pop-up.
Same thing I told my mom when it was in my history bar when I
was 15. No, it's like this person gets 10,000 viewers, right?
Some days maybe 15,000 some days. No, no, no. She would never
bot. It's got to be a pop-up, guys. It's got to be a pop-up.
Um yeah, this was this was one of the comments that they looked
into and watch the clip one more time. The view bot site was
in an incognito window, the 671 site was not. A regular window
cannot open an incognito pop-up on its own. That settles it right
there. She typed that in herself.
Yeah, that's rough, man. That's rough. Okay, so seems like that's
enough to say ExtraEmily was looking at the site at
Even if she hadn't bought, even if the the the receipt was fake,
she was definitely looking at that site of her own free will,
okay?
100%. Now, I've got I think two Asmongold clips about this. Took
a look at this. And he's reviewing it. Let's take a listen. >> And
uh you know, it showed like this right here. viewbot.ai.
Not good. So, uh was removed by a member of our moderator team.
They stated, I removed this thread because it looks like the
viewbot.ai website is a pop-up from the 67 speed website that
appeared when she opened to try to do the challenge. The mod
team tried themselves, but could not recreate the pop-up on our
own end. We did multiple browsers in >> Oh, now I do wonder.
Did Miss have some proof that Valencia the Valencia sis guy was
the person who removed it? Cuz then it seems fine. If that was
who did it. I was just saying like you hadn't proven it yet.
>> Anyway, incognito, mobile, everything, and we could
not recreate the pop-up. >> And these are the people who
like I'm sorry. His hairline is fine. >> Anybody who believed
this is a pop-up >> What the heck?
>> should have their internet privileges
>> Are are you Are you like Are you like one of these >> I
think she looked it up herself. I do. If I click this, it should
give me the pop-up, right? >> Oh, yeah. No, I'm saying
we know it's him now. When they say it's him and he's removed,
which I didn't even actually go through and make sure it was
him that was removed. But given that Listen, I'm going to assume
he was removed and I'm going to actually just leave that as what
I think cuz if I find out that more than one of their moderators
was an extra Emily power clipper and spammed extra Emily's chat
logs or chat, I'm going to be disappointed, okay? I'm just going
to I'm going to assume it's him. If there's literally two of
them,
I bro, we're cooked. It's over. >> moderator team said
that >> Oh, no. I feel I know what happened to me. I just
Oh, no. And like that was it. Oh, no. She would never do that.
You're just going to have to believe me. And that's >> And
paid actor, exactly. >> We have decided to remove this
mod from the team. We promise to be more transparent in our moderation
and if we screw up, we think it's important to be open about
it. Thank you to the members of the community
>> and Miss Kif on the same team. >> community who
reached out during the to challenge the original claims of a
So, there you go.
There you go. >> Rare Reddit mod W. >> If I pull
this up, she's not even botting. Like if you look at a handful
of these streams, like I looked at this before. This is not that
Actually, this one is pretty this this does look >> That
was pretty Ixy there.
>> But you get When you get like 95% of your viewership
within like 5 minutes, that's pretty rough. Unless there's massive
events happening. When you got 95% of your viewership within
like 5 minutes of starting the stream?
Like I think these botting sites almost certainly would have
some like parameter to make sure that doesn't happen. So you
have a more gradual grow up, right?
Like I think if I look at my streams, it's like a way more gradual
curve for the first hour or two. And then like for hours two
to five or two to six, it's like hitting its peak. And then after
that it falls off.
But these people just like instant all the way up, all the way
to the top. [__] crazy. >> This one This one
does look pretty bad. Uh this one this uh this one does look
kind of uh this kind of doesn't look >> Dude, the extra
Emily sweep was so ingrained in Asmongold's head. He just started
with it. It doesn't even look like she's botting if you open
these up. Oh
Well, she You know, it's kind of looks like she's botting a little
bit >> Okay, it doesn't look It does not look >> Right.
I mean like I I I mean it could be something else, but it does
not really look I mean the viewership [snorts] going down for
like a sponsor makes sense. Like this one like I mean is not
really that crazy, but you know, it's like it it's kind of hard
to say. It's not black and white. That's gray. >> It is.
I like extra Emily. She's a friend of mine. Like but that that's